-You've been very vocal about
the Time's Up movement
and I want to -- I read
something really interesting
about how you reached out and I
think there was a lot of people
last year around this time
reaching out to one another
in the community, in the
entertainment community,
and Brie Larson said that when
you reached out,
she kind of realized she didn't
have a lot of peers
that she was friends with.
Was that something that you
found as well that because
how Hollywood works
and how casts work,
that you just have less
interaction with...
-Yeah.
-...who you would
consider your peers?
-Yeah, it's this
weird thing where
there's usually
a girl in the movie.
It's like the Smurfette syndrome
where it's, like, all guys
and then there's the girl
in the movie, you know,
and so we rarely get the
chance to work together.
And so it was this weird thing
where we had kind of, like,
seen each other at a party
or met briefly,
you know, for a second,
but this was the first time
that we were all in a room
talking to each other,
sharing stories and, like,
connecting and working together.
It's been a completely
life-changing thing.
-I'm so happy that
that's happening.
Also, obviously
it's the holidays.
Do you have holiday plans?
Do you have things
you're going to do?
-Yeah. Um, well,
we had Hanukkah already.
-Right. Of course.
-So that was great.
A lot of, um, a lot of latkes...
-Yes.
-...and jelly doughnuts
were eaten.
-We made a huge mistake
the day of the first night
of Hanukkah, we were like,
"We should order some latkes."
And then every place
we called is like,
"Are you kidding me?
You don't think the latkes
have been ordered?"
-Yeah, that's amateur hour.
-Yeah. That was amateur.
[ Laughter ]
-But I had a weird, like,
Jewish holiday thing this year
in that, so my cousin, Meryl,
moved from New York
to L.A. last year.
She's an incredible illustrator
and she moved out
with her husband,
and so we've been inviting
them to all our Jewish holidays
and everything, and then I --
the last three holidays,
she, like, didn't reply,
and I was like, "Did I do
something to offend her?
Did I hurt her feelings?
Is she holding a grudge?"
And I was like,
"She's totally not
that type of person, I'm just
going to text her and be, like,
'Hey, you know, we're having
Yom Kippur break-fast.
Like, come over.'"
And so I looked when
I went to text her,
and I realized I had two Meryls
in my phonebook
and I'd been texting
Meryl Streep.
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"Oh, no. Oh, no."
So of course, I called and
explained and so my cousin,
Meryl, who's an illustrator,
made me this.
I brought this to show you.
-This is really fantastic.
I'll let you read it
for everyone.
-She wrote "Natalie, may you be
inscribed in the book of life
and stop texting me."
[ Laughter ]
So, thank you, both Meryls...
-Both Meryls.
-...for understanding.
-Thank you.
Well, it's just lovely to have
you here. Thank you so much.
And I hope to see you soon.